this is this is an interesting time to
be alive in tulsa specifically to be a
black person
tulsa oklahoma is undergoing a rapid
change once known as an oil capital of
the world the midwestern city now has
its sights set on a new title the
nation's most inclusive tech hub where
we are right now is in greenwood right
now and this is what's left kind of of
historic black wall street tyrants
billingsley is a native tulsan and the
founder of black tech street he's
working to attract entrepreneurs and
investments into tulsa's budding tech
scene part of what black texture means
to do is to be this banner that inspires
black people to say
i'm what the next tech ceo can look like
i'm what the technologist that might
help
solve climate change looks like
black tech street reimagines a new
legacy for the awful events of 1921 when
a white mob wiped out the greenwood
district also known as black wall street
the property damage alone was roughly 25
million dollars in today's money
movie theaters grocery stores libraries
were all raised to the ground businesses
that made this one of america's most
prosperous black neighborhoods
what i heard about the massacre to be
honest i didn't actually focus on the
massacre what was incredible to me was
the fact that i grew up on the grounds
of what was once the most prosperous
african-american community of
entrepreneurs in the history of the
country i mean that's
to a young person who wants to find out
that there's something special about
them it's like hagrid telling harry he
was a wizard you know i was like you
know that's some incredible that's some
incredible lineage i remember when i
first heard about it
and that was in
ninth grade oklahoma history but it
wasn't until very recently that i really
learned about the actual atrocities that
occurred mikhail vaughan has returned to
tulsa after 10 years of living in japan
he now leads urban coders guild a
non-profit that provides computer
sciences training and opportunities for
black and brown youth i had an amazing
life in tokyo but what i didn't have was
a sense of purpose as a young man who
grew up in tulsa i knew that it was my
responsibility my obligation really to
come home and provide those same
opportunities in their classes the guild
teaches middle and high school students
how to build websites create apps and
digital games last year we did the black
wall street business directory super
proud of that that project kettle spent
about half a year learning how to build
a website html css a bit of java we put
them all together and we created a
website that
focused on all the businesses that
existed in historic greenwood to really
celebrate those entrepreneurs
what they were able to build and then
imagining if those businesses existed
today they would most likely have a
website
the kiddos are building websites they're
building mobile apps they're building
their own games and this really just
isn't something that our our schools
have the capacity to teach right now we
want to do something fun and innovative
and make sure that this is available to
kids across our school district and
initiatives like vaughn's aren't the
only to have recognized education as the
key to making the vision of tulsa as a
leader for tech a reality i
love working with entrepreneurs i love
knowing what people are dreaming about
taylor is another native tolson in her
role she provides education for
entrepreneurs specifically from black
brown and under-resourced communities
and i think one of the most rewarding
experiences for me is when someone sits
in my office and says
wow like i didn't even know
that i was this close a lot of times
when i'm working with
under-resourced entrepreneurs
no one is thinking about how to scale
their business into 15 different states
right away people are thinking
how do i make money on just one or two
customers and being able to say well hey
do you know this person hey did you know
that we have this loan program let's put
it all on the board and see what are
your multiple options here together
taylor vaughn and billingsley form part
of what is becoming a budding ecosystem
of support support that has been sorely
lacking in this community the origin of
actually black tech street is i begin to
ask myself the question you know what
could black wall street have been had it
been supported and not destroyed and you
know looking at the level of tenacity
that it took for these black
entrepreneurs to build these incredible
businesses during jim crow that smashing
through walls thinking outside of the
box it reminded me a lot of the tech
industry and when i coupled that with
the fact that technology is one of the
only industries you can build
intergenerational wealth in seven to ten
years in and that by the year 2030 there
will be 4.3 million vacant tech jobs due
to a tech talent shortage i not only saw
an incredible wealth building
opportunity for black people i kind of
saw the black wall street vision pushed
to a new horizon
how do we stimulate
the wealth and the essence in the spirit
that used to live here
and
what i have found personally in the work
that i'm doing is that the spirit still
is here all eyes are on us so what a
better time than now